we're calling her cider to protect her
identity she lives in Northeast Delhi
and hasn't heard from her brother in 10
days she's afraid for both their safety
cider says that on April 10th police
came to their home and asked her brother
to go to the police station to make a
statement about being shot during the
communal violence in Delhi in February
wei-shou-bou I was they called us 9:00
at night and said we're not gonna let
him go because we've seen footage of him
and he lied to us we asked them to show
us proof but they didn't they said we'll
show it in court but how can we go to
court when it's shut they haven't let us
see him or give him food cider doesn't
know if police have charged her brother
since the lockdown began four weeks ago
he's one of dozens of people arrested in
connection with the attacks fifty-three
people were killed in the worst violence
the Delhi territory in decades it began
when supporters of the government's
citizenship Amendment Act fought with
protesters complaining the doll was
anti-muslim even though we've had
reports of illegal arrests and
detentions even before the lockdown
before the lockdown lawyers were still
able to physically visit police stations
they were able to make it to courts to
file applications needed to protect the
rights of the arrestees those options
are unfortunately no longer available
because of the restrictions on caught
functioning also arrested a prominent
members of the citizenship law protest
movement including Maidan hi there a
research scholar at Jamia Millia Islamia
University among the charges against him
rioting murder sedition and promoting
hostility between religious groups civil
society organizations say police are
trying to blame Muslim leaders like
Haider for February's violence while
ignoring members of the Hindu majority
Bharatiya janta party who openly called
for attacks on protesters picking them
up charging them of daily violence
looking for conspiracy angle at a time
when all of us are fighting pandemic
this is scary scary not only for the
students who have been arrested scaring
for the very health of democracy the MP
and hiders lawyer told Al Jazeera the
charges against him and others are
baseless
please didn't respond to Al Jazeera's
request for an interview but they
tweeted saying Delhi Police has done its
job sincerely and impartial II and all
the arrests made have been based on
scientific and forensic evidence
including video footage cider and her
parents and many other families are
still waiting to hear what the evidence
or charges against their loved ones are
Elizabeth puranam al Jazeera New Delhi